[musique]
c'est toujours dangereux, on a peur, pour ainsi dire
J'ai entendu toute mon enfance sous le DPR en tant qu'enfant dans
guerre des bombardements
les chars ont roulé autour de la ville quand nous
des amis sont allés se promener en quelque sorte pas très
vue d'enfance quand les chars s'en vont
des hommes armés
rien mais un peu de stress bien sûr
il y avait au début un peu peur mais
puis il s'est habitué et maintenant
les explosions et les coups de feu sont déjà si courants
En fait
habituellement
[musique]
pouvez-vous pouvez-vous aller un instant
quelque part en vacances, et pour cela nous avons besoin
collecter un tas de documents n'est pas le fait que vous
pas les faits vous lâcheront au courant alors tout
expériences
puis l'import export de produits souffle
marchandises, c'est-à-dire que tout est difficile
les achats se font dans des magasins en ligne, nous ne le faisons pas
Nous pouvons nous permettre
la livraison du courrier en provenance d'autres pays est tout
rend la vie très difficile, donc il y a un tel
le sentiment que nous sommes en quelque sorte détachés
paix
[musique]
Je n'ai pas encore envisagé cette option
mais peut-être que pour commencer au moins vous avez besoin
essayer la Russie pour obtenir
un diplôme normal de devenir soi-même en tant que
un spécialiste, c'est-à-dire une certaine expérience et
alors déjà une revendication sur l'Europe ou
à d'autres pays plus développés
[musique]